l'ex en aura c'est devenu tellement
difficile que ceux qui n'arrivent pas à
passer par l'europe centrale tente
maintenant leur chance beaucoup plus
loin par la russie c'est une route tout
à fait inusitée c'est bien on n'aurait
jamais cru que les gens puissent se
lancer dans une telle aventure
alors les réfugiés syriens parce qu'ils
sont pour la plupart syrien partent donc
de syrie se retrouve à istanbul ou à
beyrouth et de là ils prennent l'avion
jusqu'en russie à moscou la capitale de
la russie et de moscou ils prennent
l'avion jusqu'à moore maïs là on est à
presque 500 km au nord du cercle polaire
de murmansk ils ont deux heures à faire
en voiture pour se rendre à la frontière
norvégienne la norvège s'est déjà
l'espace schengen c'est déjà l'europe
alors de là ils peuvent partir ailleurs
mais pour se rendre pour traverser la
frontière
ils ne peuvent pas le faire en voiture
parce que les norvégiens arrête les
conducteurs de voitures en les faisant
passer pour des passeurs en soupçonnant
que ce sont des passeurs et les russes
ne permet pas la traversée à pied
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font ces réfugiés
il agirait qu'est ce qui leur reste
ils achètent des vélos des vélos usagers
souvent et traversent la frontière en
vélo et abandonne ses dizaines des
centaines de vélos de l'autre côté de la
frontière
et c'est une route qui de plus en plus
emprunter avec l'hiver qui s'en vient
peut-être que ça va se tarir
mais pour le moment le nombre de
réfugiés double chaque semaine par cette
voie là et au cours des dernières
semaines il ya eu mille 600 réfugiés
syriens qui sont arrivés par la
frontière russo norvégienne gens qui
sont prêts à tout pour arsenal
absolument merci beaucoup alexandra
plaisir